wie viele menschen braucht man
eigentlich für die reise zum mit 4,2
lichtjahren entfernung nächstgelegenen
exoplaneten proxima centauri b
eine berechtigte frage denn eine crew
mit heute üblichen drei astronauten oder
astronauten würden nicht ankommen
sondern sie würden vorher sterben was
also tun das rätsel wo sie jetzt gelöst
und die lösung erfahrt ihr hier bei
pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
knapp 7000 zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
haben gestern auf unserem kanal an der
abstimmung teilgenommen und zu 67 für
dieses thema gestimmt mit wie vielen
menschen muss man hier von der erde aus
starten damit überhaupt jemand auf dem
exoplaneten proxima centauri b ankommt 3
wie meistens heute üblich das sind zu
wenig aber wie viele genau diese frage
haben jetzt frederik macher von der
universität straßburg und kamelblut vom
forschungsunternehmen kaskade
beantwortet um sie zu beantworten
mussten sie erst einmal ein paar
voraussetzungen festlegen unter anderem
wie lange dauert eigentlich die reise
sie kommen zum schluss dass es mit
heutiger technik 6300 jahre dauern würde
proxima centauri zu erreichen okay also
gibt es schon mal ein kleines problem
die stadt besatzung würde niemals das
ziel erreichen und überhaupt würden die
meisten besatzungsmitglieder weder die
erde noch proxima centauri geht zum
gesicht bekommen es muss also dafür
gesorgt werden so die forscherinnen und
der forscher dass genügend
besatzungsmitglieder an bord sind die
sich zum einen fortpflanzen können und
zum anderen um erbschäden zu vermeiden
nicht verwandt sein dürfen
bei ihrer simulation mit dem algorithmus
heritage gingen sie davon aus dass sich
die besatzung alle 32 bis 40 jahre fort
fans zu dem simulierten sie eine
katastrophe bei der ein drittel der
besatzung starb dazu kam noch natürliche
todesfälle und tödliche unfälle
das ergebnis es werden 49 paare
beziehungsweise 98 personen für die
besatzung benötigt die raumschiffe
dielen was für die marsmission plan
hätten also genau die richtige größe
ich frage mich allerdings wie die
versorgung aussehen soll vorräte für
6300 jahre wird man bekommen mitnehmen
können und selbstversorgung pflanzen
die basis dafür würden im dunkel des
weltraums wohl kaum wachsen energie für
künstliche beleuchtung wo es weil die
kommen
ich freue mich über eure ideen und links
zu in den kommentaren ich mache daraus
dann ein video in dem ich mit euren in
denen eine solche mission plane ich bin
sehr gespannt es gibt aber laut den
beiden noch weitere nicht kalkulierbare
unwägbarkeiten verändert sich die
fruchtbarkeit im weltall treten durch
die kosmische strahlung mutationen auf
gebe es dadurch weniger gesunde kinder
dann würde die fortpflanzung nicht mehr
funktionieren gibt es dafür aber weniger
katastrophen und unfälle
fragen über fragen also eure ideen in
die kommentare und schon bald fliegen
wird zumindest virtuell zu proxima
centauri wenn ihr dieses video und alle
anderen videos nicht verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann
umgehend ihr die kaputte a proxy auf
youtube und verpasst kann video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
kriegs um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt aktuelle hat thomas dort den bahn-
fall aufgeklärt dafür hier klicken aber
nicht die genau die glocke vergessen und
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken außerirdisches leben auf
proxima centauri b bis dann bleibt dran